we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 David P here's a
voicemail uh that I'm getting many
versions of asking about masks take a
listen to this
hey David Pac-Man yeah I just want to
tell you I'm a big fan of your show
sounds ominous and I use you as a
resource for most of my day-to-day
habits and I just want to thank you for
all the hard work you do thank you I
recently have been intrigued by the um
kind of new
new Delta variant of the coven 19. yeah
uh virus and I was wondering are you
going to be wearing your mask again
because I think I am
I think I'm going to be wearing my Mask
full force again and I've been
vaccinated twice by the Pfizer and I was
just wondering if you or anyone else is
kind of uh
looking forward to wearing her mask
again I can't say I'm looking forward to
it but I'm expecting it the way the
Delta variant is spreading and you know
we all want to think optimistically but
when you look at the case Trend right
now again it's mostly hitting on
vaccinated people but the vaccines
aren't 100 effective so even if you're
vaccinated you you could still get it
although the risk is quite low
if you see the direction of things right
now and we know how long it takes to
develop immunity we're in mid-july
we're not that far from the start of flu
season I sort of think of the start of
flu season as September 1st even though
technically it might be a little bit
later
there is every indication that there is
going to be significant additional
masking in the fall now do I expect that
I'll be wearing masks in small groups of
vaccinated friends I don't I don't
expect that no
um but do I think that certainly uh in
indoor places I mean listen right now
when I go to the grocery store
basically no one's wearing masks anymore
and I tend to go at times where it's not
busy I'm not wearing my mask right now I
anticipate probably by September 15th I
will be back to wearing my mask in
grocery stores and
um my my belief is we're going to see a
lot of more more of that now in red
States you know it's not going to be
ubiquitous but I think parts of the
country that took this seriously to
begin with are going to take it
seriously again we've got a great bonus
show for you today we've got a lot of
great stuff on it sign up at
joinpakman.com we will speak to you
momentarily on that bonus show if you
are a member otherwise I'll see you
tomorrow